The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
LAURA SCHULZ: So what
you've heard by now
is that the hard problem
of cognitive science
turns out to be the problem
of commonsense reasoning.
Our computers can drive.
They can perform
fabulous calculations.
They can beat us at Jeopardy!
But when it comes to all
of the really hard problems
of cognitive science, there's
only one organism that solves
them, and that's a human child.
And those are problems of face
recognition, scene recognition,
motor planning, natural language
acquisition, causal reasoning,
theory of mind, moral reasoning.
All of those are solved in
largely unsupervised learning
by children by the age of five.
And those are the things
our computers don't do well.
And that is largely because the
problem of human intelligence,
common sense
intelligence, is a problem
of drawing really rich
inferences that are massively
underdetermined by the data.
So to make that
point really clear,
I'm to give you all a pop
intelligence quiz, OK?
So here's the pop
intelligence quiz.
Can I see a show
of hands, please--
how many of you think
that I have a spleen?
Can I see a show of hands?
Excellent.
How many of you would care--
keep your hands down
if you're an M.D.
But other than that,
how many of you
would care to come
up here and diagram,
for the class, a spleen,
and explain what it is,
where it is, and what its exact
function is in the human body?
Anyone?
How many of you
have met me before?
A few of you.
But most of you, without
knowing anything about spleens,
and not knowing
anything about me,
are nonetheless extremely
confident that I have one.
So you have a lot of
abstract knowledge
in the absence of
really much in the way
of specific, concrete facts.
OK, let me give you
another problem.
Of course, it's a kind
of classic one from--
by the way, for those of you who
are curious, that's a spleen.
All right, classic--
these problems
crop up in every aspect of
human cognition, all right?
What's behind the rectangle?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LAURA SCHULZ: Right.
You all know.
You can't articulate
it, but you know.
And the fact that
there are infinitely
many other hypotheses
consistent with the data
doesn't trouble you at
all, doesn't stop you
from converging, collectively,
on a single answer, which
means there has to be a lot
of constraints on how you're
interpreting this kind of data.
Here's another one.
Complete the sentence.
AUDIENCE: Very long neck.
LAURA SCHULZ: Very long neck--
could be, or temper,
or flight to Kenya.
There are many things
that it could be.
In this case, it looks
like a frequency issue.
Oh, well, "neck" is
a very common word.
Others aren't.
But if I said, "giraffes are
really common on the African--"
you would say "savannah,"
not "television," OK?
So you're using a lot
of rich information
to take a tiny bit of data
and draw rich inferences.
And that is the problem,
and the hard problem,
of common sense
intelligence, and I
think, a real dissociation
between what we do
and what our children do.
Human intelligence uses abstract
structured representations
to constrain the
hypotheses and make
these kind of
outrageous inferences
that we shouldn't
be able to make.
That's all well
and good, but where
do these abstract structured
representations come from?
And there's only
two possibilities--
we're born with them,
or we learn them.
Liz Spelke has already told
you a lot about the reasons
to think that we are
born with many of them,
and so true for
anything that might
be stable over
evolutionary time, that
might emerge early in ontogeny
and broadly in phylogeny.
And that's true for many
aspects of folk physics, folk
psychology, causal reasoning,
navigation, number.
But there's a lot of
other things you know.
Shoes, ships, sealing wax--
basically everything else--
they are not plausibly innate.
And so how do you learn them?
So Piaget, the
founder of our field
of developmental psychology,
says you build these up
from experience.
You build them up starting with
sensory motor representations
very, very gradually.
You progress through a lot
of concrete information
until finally, somewhere
around the age of 12,
you get to abstract
representations of the world.
But it turns out that just
like you and your spleens,
children have a lot
of abstract knowledge
before they have much of
this concrete information.
They know, actually,
almost nothing--
even less than you
know, it turns out--
about anatomy and biology.
But they know all of
these kinds of things.
Animals have insides.
Similar kinds of animals
have similar insides.
Plants and objects don't.
Removing those insides
is a bad idea usually.
They can go on and on without
really understanding anything
about anatomy or biology.
And so for you.
If I push you hard on
all kinds of things--
how does a scissors
really work--
you know, most of you would
be like, ahh, and [INAUDIBLE]
pretty quick, OK?
And we know this.
So we have these
intuitive theories
that seem to constrain
our hypothesis space.
But it's a really hard
chicken and egg problem,
because we've said we need
these rich abstract theories
to constrain the
interpretation of data.
But how do we learn
them if we don't
have concrete information?
And nonetheless, some
of them are learned.
We're going to return to
that at the end of the talk.
And really, I'm going to do that
to set up Josh and Tomer, who
are going to talk about that.
But first, what I'm
going to talk about
is-- you know, OK, why
am I talking about this
as an intuitive theory?
Where is this
argument coming from?
I'm interested in learning.
And it's a research
program that emerged
against the backdrop
of two revolutions
in our understanding of
cognitive development.
One was the infancy revolution.
You've heard a lot about it, so
I'm going to go very quickly.
Babies, it turns
out, know a lot more
than we thought about
objects, and about number,
and about agents, and their
goals, and their intentions.
It's not just infants though.
It turns out that very young
children, preschoolers, also
represent knowledge
that is not plausibly
innate in ways that are
abstract, that are coherent,
that are causal, that support
prediction, and intervention,
and explanation, and
counterfactual reasoning
in ways that seem
to justify referring
to them as intuitive theories.
And together, these
two revolutions,
the infancy revolution
and the revolution
in our understanding
of early childhood,
dismantled Piagetian
stage theory.
There was never a time--
there is never a
time-- in development
when babies are only
sensory motor learners.
There is never a time
when there is not
some level of abstract
representation going on.
But fundamentally, neither
of these revolutions
was about learning per se.
And I think I can make
that point most clear
by pointing to a popular book
that came out at the time.
The subtitle here is Minds,
Brains, and How Children Learn.
But in fact, if you
look in the book,
this was a publisher's title.
There's nothing about brains.
And there's very
little about learning.
The titles are what children
know about objects, what
children know about agents.
And I can say this with great
reverence and some authority,
because the first author's
my thesis advisor.
And the book came
out in 1999, which
is the year I started
graduate school.
So literally and metaphorically,
this is where I began.
I began with this metaphor
of the child as scientist.
And it's a really
problematic metaphor,
because science is a
historically and culturally
specific practice
that is practiced
by a tiny minority
of the human species
and is difficult
even for us, right?
So it seems a really
odd place to look
for a universal metaphor
for cognitive development.
But science has this
peculiar property,
which is that it
gets the world right.
And if you really want to
understand how new knowledge is
possible, how you could
get the world right,
you might want to understand
how scientists do it,
what kinds of
epistemic practices
might support learning
and discovery.
And the answer to that is both
that we do and do not know,
which is to say we can
say a lot of things
about what scientists do.
Here are some of them.
They'll all be familiar to you.
They would be familiar to
you if you were a physicist,
if you were in aero-astro,
if you were in paleontology.
These are the kinds of
scientific practices
that cut across content
domains and arguably define
what science is,
which is to say,
if you did all of these things,
you couldn't necessarily
do science.
Science requires bringing
these inferential processes
to bear on really
rich, specific,
conceptual representations of
individual content domains.
But arguably, if you had all
of that rich, specific content
knowledge and you
didn't do these things,
you couldn't learn
anything at all.
These are the kinds
of epistemic practices
that seem fundamental to
inquiry and discovery.
And the argument that I've
made in my research program
is they are fundamental
not just in science, they
are fundamental in
cognitive development.
These are the processes that
support learning and discovery.
And there's good evidence that
each and every one of them
emerges in some form in the
first few years of life.
And that is because these are
the only rational processes
we know of that can solve the
hard problem of learning, which
is exactly the
problem of how to draw
rich abstract entrances
rapidly and accurately
from sparse, noisy data.
I said we could characterize
these practices both formally
and informally.
And indeed, as you've
heard, I think,
from some of our computational
modeling colleagues,
for each and every one
of these practices,
we can begin to
characterize something
about what it means
to distinguish
genuine causes from
spurious associations
or to optimize information gain.
But with all due respect to
my computational modeling
colleagues, and much as we
want really simple models--
Hebb's rule,
Rescorla-Wagner, Bayes' law--
that would capture
it, none of these
do justice to what
children can do.
Because children can
do all of these things.
And we don't yet have
a full formal theory
of hypothesis, generation,
inquiry, and discovery.
That remains a hard problem
of cognitive science.
But it's a problem
to which I think
our theories should aspire.
Because there is
good empirical data
that this is the kind of
learning that humans, including
even very young
children, engage in.
So normally, at this point,
what I would do is I'd say,
and I'm going to show you
a few examples of this
from my research program.
But the talk I'm giving here
is a sort of funny throwback
talk in some ways.
What I was asked
to talk about today
was the child as scientist.
And that was a research program
from a few, few years ago.
And you know, at that point,
I was a junior professor.
And you know, when you're
a junior professor,
like when you're a graduate
student or post-doc,
it's all idealistic science
for the sake of knowledge,
pure science.
And then you get tenure.
And it's all grants, and
money, and administration,
and allocation of resources.
And in the years
since, I have started
to think not just about the
pure science of learning,
but about the cost associated
with gaining information
and the trade-offs between
those costs and rewards.
So I'm going to take these same
practices now, and situate them
in a world, a real world, that
has certain kinds of trade-offs
in how you think about
information and talk,
along with the
child as scientist,
about what those costs
do and how they are also,
in themselves, a source of
information about the world.
So I'm going to talk
about this as sort
of inferential economics.
Children know
information is valuable.
I'm going to show you
a couple of examples
of how they reason about it.
And children selectively
explore in ways
that support information gain.
So I'm going to show
you some old work,
but I'm also going to
throw in a few new studies,
because I can't resist.
But information is also costly.
And the costs themselves
are informative in a variety
of ways.
I'm not necessarily going to get
through all of these studies,
although I might try to.
But I want to give you a kind
of feel for the kinds of things
children can do.
All right, so let's
start by talking
about a really basic problem.
It's a problem that's
basic to science,
but it's also a problem basic
to human learning, which is
the problem of generalization.
How do you generalize
from sparse data?
In science, we do
this all the time.
We have a small sample.
We want to make a claim about
the population as a whole.
And of course, we can use
feature similarity and category
membership to say things
that look the same
or belong to the same kind are
likely to share properties.
So if some of
these Martian rocks
have high concentrations of
silica, maybe they all do.
If some of these needles
on Pacific silver fir trees
grow flat on the branch,
maybe they all do.
But in science, we can also
do something a little more
fussy and suspicious.
We can say, well,
you know, it kind of
depends on how you got that
sample of evidence, right?
If you randomly sampled from
the population, yeah, sure,
the properties,
you can generalize.
But if you cherry-picked
that data in some way,
maybe the sample isn't going
to generalize quite as broadly.
So do all Martian rocks have
high concentrations of silica
or just the dusty
ones on the surface?
Do all Pacific silver fir
needles lie flat or just
those low on the canopy, right?
These are the ones that
are easy to sample from.
How do I know how
generalizable the property is?
And if I think that you
cherry-picked your sample,
I might constrain my inferences
only to things near the ground.
So how far you're
going to extend
a generalization in
science depends on
whether you think that
the sampling process was
random or selective.
And we wanted to know whether
this was true for babies
as well.
So this is how we asked.
We showed babies a
population, in this case,
of blue and yellow dog toys.
They're in a box.
The box is transparent, has
a false front so it stays
a less stable representation of
what looks like a lot of balls.
And we're going to
reach into that box.
And we're going to pull out--
there are many more blue balls
in this box than yellow balls.
We're going to pull out three
blue balls one at a time
and squeak them--
and squeeze them-- and
they're going to squeak.
And then we're going to
hand the baby a yellow ball
from the same box.
And the question is, does
the baby squeeze the ball
and expect it to squeak?
Well, there's nothing very
suspicious about pulling
three blue balls from a
box of mostly blue balls.
And this has a lot of
feature properties in common.
So it looks like the others.
We predict that children
should generalize.
They should try squeezing this
ball and should squeeze often.
And the question
is, what happens
if you do exactly the same
sample in exactly the same way
from a different population?
Now, it is very unlikely that
you sampled three blue balls
from a population of
mostly yellow balls.
In this case, it's
much more likely
that you were
sampling selectively.
So maybe only the blue
balls had the property.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: And they can
see the population?
LAURA SCHULZ: They can see the
population-- transparent box,
transparent front.
So they can see the population.
And if children
understand that it's
not just about the
property similarity
but something about how that
evidence was generated, then,
in this case, children
should say, well look,
you just looked like you were
cherry-picking your sample.
Maybe it doesn't
generalize predictions
that fewer children
should try squeaking
and children should
squeeze less often.
So I'm going to show you
what this looks like.
By the way, the yellow one has
that funny thing at the end
so that children could do
something else with the ball,
right?
So they can bang it,
or throw it around,
or other things like that.
So let me show you
what it looks like.
Kids are always going to see
three squeaky blue balls.
They're always going
to get a yellow one.
But you'll see that they do
different things depending
on whether they think--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
LAURA SCHULZ: --the evidence
was randomly sampled
and possibly
generalizable or not.
So the child at the
top is squeezing,
and squeezing, and
squeezing, and squeezing.
[END PLAYBACK]
So these were-- this was
true both of the mean number
of squeezes and the number
of individual children
who squeezed at all.
I'm just going to show you
the mean number of squeezes.
But what you'll see is
that children are much more
likely to squeeze, and
squeeze persistently,
in the condition where
the evidence looks
like it was randomly sampled
than selectively sampled.
But what you could
worry about here
is children are
sensitive to something
about the relationship of the
sample and the population.
But maybe they will
just generalize
from a majority object to a
minority, but not the reverse.
Maybe they won't generalize
from a minority object
to the majority.
So they don't really care
about whether the evidence was
randomly sampled
or not, they just
care about that aspect of
the sample and population.
So we ran a replication of
the yellow ball condition.
Again, we're going to pull an
unlikely sample from that box,
three blue balls in a row.
And we're going to compare
it with a sample that's
not that improbable.
You could easily randomly
sample just one blue ball
from the box.
So in this case,
children are going
to see much less
squeezing, right?
They're only going to see
one blue ball squeezed.
And we squeeze it both
once and three times,
but it's only one blue ball
in two different conditions.
And the prediction there is
that even though the children
themselves are seeing
much less squeezing,
they should say, well, that's
not an improbable sample.
And they, themselves,
should squeeze more.
And that's exactly what we found
in both of those conditions.
It's graded, by the way.
If you do two balls,
they're intermediate.
And if it's a model--
well, not going to talk
about-- but yeah, what
happens if you just pour them
upside down and drop them?
Now this is a really
improbable sample
I said, three blue
balls from a yellow box.
But you've just given
positive evidence
that you shook the ball, and
it just happened to fall out.
And they don't know
we're MIT, and we
can do sneaky technological
things like have a trap door.
So in this case, it's
an improbable sample,
but it was randomly generated.
And the prediction
is, in this case,
the babies themselves
should squeeze more.
Because as I say, if you can
pour out any balls that squeak,
probably everything squeaks.
And indeed, they do.
Indeed, they do.
All right?
So 15-month-old
babies' generalizations
take into account more
than category membership
and the perceptual
similarity of objects.
They make graded inferences
that are sensitive
both to the amount of
evidence they observe
and to the process by which
that evidence is sampled.
Is that clear?
All right, let me show
you another example
of sort of child as scientist.
It's going to start with a
hard problem of confounding
that we all have, which is
that we are part of the world.
So in one-offs, when
things go wrong,
we may not know if
we were responsible
or the world was
responsible, right?
This is a chronic problem
in relationships, right--
you or me?
So it's a hard problem
of confounding,
and you might need some
data to disambiguate it.
So here we're going to give
babies a case where they cannot
do something.
And the question
is, can we give them
a little bit of data to
unconfound that problem
and convince them either
that the problem is probably
with the toy or the
problem is with themselves?
And the argument is, if they
think that it's themselves
that's the problem--
it's the agent state and
not the environment state--
they should hold the toy
constant and change the agent.
But if they think it's
the toy, then they
should just go ahead and
reach for another toy.
So in both cases, they're
going to have access
to another person, their mom.
And they're going to have
access to another toy.
And so the question
is, what do they
do if we give them
minimal statistical data
to disambiguate these, OK?
So this is the setup.
We're going to show
the babies two agents.
In one condition, I am going
to succeed one time at making
that toy go and fail one time.
And Hyowon Gweon, my
collaborator on this project,
is also going to fail
and succeed once.
So this looks like this
toy has maybe faulty wiring
or something.
It works some of the
time, not all the time.
It's just not a great toy.
The babies can have another toy.
The parents are
going to be there.
If they think it's the toy,
they should change the object.
In the other condition, Hyowon
is always going to succeed,
which is generally
true in my experience.
And as is always true of my
experience in technology,
I am always going to fail.
And in this case,
the children should
conclude that there's something
wrong with the person.
And if that's the case, they
should hold the object constant
and change the agent.
This is what it looks like.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- [INAUDIBLE]
LAURA SCHULZ: We've lost sound.
Well there's an audio
here, but [INAUDIBLE] we
are going to want that later.
- Cool What happened to my toys?
LAURA SCHULZ: In any case,
were just showing them
the data at this point.
And the babies are going to
get the toy in each condition.
One toy is on the mat.
By the way, there are lots
of individual differences
in any two sets of clips
between the exact positioning
of the parent, the
child, the toy.
All of these were
coded blind conditions
for all of these other
variables to make
sure those were evenly
matched across conditions,
and they were.
So what you're going
to see now though is
that in the condition where
the babies think it is probably
the toy, they engage in
a very different behavior
than when they think
it is probably agent.
- [CRYING]
- [INAUDIBLE]
[END PLAYBACK]
And that's what
we found overall.
The distribution, overall,
of children's tendency
to perform one
action versus another
differed across conditions
depending on the pattern
of data that they observed.
So 16-month-olds track
the statistical dependence
between agents,
objects, and outcomes.
They can use minimal data
to make attributions.
And they help them choose
between seeking help
from others or
exploring on their own.
Clear?
OK.
I've just shown you kids'
sensitivity to the data
that they see.
But of course, data isn't
handed out all the time.
At least disambiguating
data isn't handed out.
One of the really
important, hard things
that you have to do
if you want to learn
is sometimes actually
figure out what data would
be informative and go get it.
And that is a really
characteristic thing
about science.
And the question is,
is it, in some sense,
a characteristic thing
about common sense.
So that's what we're
going to ask here.
We're going to jump to
much older children here.
These are four and
five-year-olds.
And we're going to give
them a problem where
instead of showing them
the disambiguating data,
we're going to ask if the
kids themselves will find it.
So what we showed children--
when you were little,
you possibly played
with some beads
that snapped together
and pulled apart.
These are like toddler toys.
So we gave them these
snap together beads.
They're each uniquely colored.
We place each bead, one
at a time, on a toy.
And in one condition, every
bead makes the toy play music
to each bead you put on.
And the other condition,
only half the beads did.
So the only difference
between these two conditions
is basically the base rate
of the candidate causes.
One works for every bead,
the other only works
for some of the beads.
And then we took all
these training toys away,
and we showed the
children either a pair
that we had epoxied
together-- it was stuck.
We tried to pull it apart,
we showed we couldn't.
The children tried to pull
it apart, they couldn't.
It's a stuck pair
of beads, or it's
an ordinary, separable
pair of beads.
And then, as a pair, we placed
each pair, one at a time,
on the toy, and the
toy played music.
In principle, this evidence
is always confounded.
One bead in each pair might
be the responsible party
activating the toy.
But as a practical
matter, if you just
learn the base rate is that
every single bead activates
this toy, there's not a lot of
information to be gained here.
You should just assume that
all of these beads work.
And in that
condition, we expected
that kids would play
indiscriminately
with the two toys.
But in the condition where
only some of the beads work,
there's genuine uncertainty.
Right?
Maybe only one of
these beads work.
Maybe they both did.
And if that's true,
and if kids are
sensitive to the possibility
of information gain,
only one of these beads affords
the possibility of finding out.
On only one can you
isolate the variables.
And that's with
the separable pair.
So we thought on this condition,
the kids should selectively
play with the separable pair.
And in particular, they should
place each bead, one at a time,
on the toy.
So that's, in
fact, what we find.
In the obvious condition,
the kids basically
never separated the pair.
And in the some beads
condition, about half the kids
did it and performed the
exhaustive intervention.
That was cool, but my graduate
student at the time said,
they're doing something
really interesting
even with the stuck
pair of beads.
We should look at
the stuck pair.
And I said, what can they
do with the stuck pair?
There's nothing to be
done with the stuck pair.
It's stuck.
And she said, well,
let's just try it again
with the stuck pair.
So we did the same thing.
They got introduced the fact
that either every bead worked,
or only some of
the beads worked.
And this time we introduced
just the stuck pair,
and we placed it on the
toy, and the toy made music.
And let me show you
what the children did.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- All right, I'm
going to do this one,
and then it'll be your
turn a little later.
But now, can you just watch
and see watch happens?
All right.
This one makes the machine go.
How about this one?
This one doesn't
make the machine go.
What about this one?
This one doesn't
make the machine go.
Let's try this one.
This one makes the machine go.
LAURA SCHULZ: She goes
over that a second time,
and then she hands
the child the toy.
- Just a minute.
- Look at that.
[END PLAYBACK]
LAURA SCHULZ: The child plays
around, does just what we did.
And then she does
something we'd never done.
She rotates the
position of the bead
so that only one makes contact
with the toy at a time.
And if you have a folk
theory of contact causality,
that is a pretty good way
to isolate your variables.
And not one that had
occurred to, say, the PI
on this investigation.
But in fact, it
occurred to about half
the kids again,
in that condition.
In the some beads condition,
where there was uncertainty,
the kids were more likely to
design their own intervention
to try to isolate the variables
than in the condition where
all the beads worked.
So preschoolers are
using information
about the base rate
of candidate causes
to distinguish the
ambiguity of the evidence,
and they're selecting
and designing
potentially informative
interventions to isolate
these causal variables.
All right.
I'm going to show
you some new work
now, kind of on the same theme.
One way that investigations
can be uninformative
is because evidence
is confounded.
We're all familiar
with that, right?
We think we did the perfect
experiment, then we're like,
oh, well, it really could have
been because of this really
silly, boring reason.
And that's disappointing.
And we have to run it again.
But another reason
that investigations
can be uninformative is because
they generate outcomes that
are super hard to distinguish.
So if I have a
handkerchief in one pocket,
and a candy cane in
the other, then a child
who wants that
candy cane is going
to have no trouble patting
you down and finding the candy
cane.
But if I have a
pen in one pocket
and a candy cane in
the other, that's
going to be a harder problem.
And this might be more
salient to you if I say,
you're going to go in and have
a lab test for a fatal disease,
or potentially a benign disease.
And you know what the results
are going to look like?
One is going to
be reddish maroon,
and the other is going
to be maroonish red.
OK, that's not the
kind of test you want.
You want yellow, blue, right?
So this is important.
We care about how
much uncertainty there
is over interpreting
the outcome as well.
So if children are sensitive
to how useful actions are
for information gain,
then they should
prefer interventions that
generate distinctive patterns
of evidence.
So Max Siegel in my lab has
been running some experiments
like this.
He started with a very
simple one, basically
the equivalent of the
handkerchief and the candy
cane.
He said, OK, there's either
a bean bag in this box
that I'm going to put in
here, or a pencil in this box.
It is a shiny, cool,
hologram, sparkly pencil.
You'll want it.
That's going to go in
this box over here.
And in this box,
either the really cool,
shiny hologram pencil, or the
really boring yellow pencil
is going to go in this box.
And guess what I'm going to do?
I'm going to take each box,
and I'm going to shake it.
So he does that.
And you know what
you hear both times?
Ka-thunk, ka-thunk, ka-thunk.
Indistinguishable sounds.
And now the question is,
which box do you want to open?
Which box you want to open?
Right?
And if you're sensitive
to the ambiguity,
you should say, well,
listen, if it were a beanbag,
I would really know, so that
must be the sparkly pencil,
right?
But I'm never going
to know in this box,
because both pencils are
going to sound alike,
so I really better
choose this box.
And then he's going to
do a harder problem.
He's going to say, there are
eight shiny, colorful marbles--
you really want them--
in this box, or two
really boring white ones.
Or there are eight colorful,
shiny marbles in this box,
or six really boring white ones.
In each case, they
each get hidden, you're
going to hear the box.
In each case, it's going to make
exactly the same sound, which
is actually the sound of
eight marbles in a box.
And the question is, which
box do you want to open?
So let me show you
how that works.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- [INAUDIBLE] and I
also have some marbles.
Well, you see these marbles
right here, the white ones?
These are Bunny's.
Oh, six of my marbles, yay.
Oh, two of my marbles, yay.
Guess what, Taylor?
These marbles with lots
of different colors, those
are yours for right now.
That's pretty cool, right?
Those are your marbles.
That's awesome.
And in this game, I'm
going to hide either
your marbles or Bunny's
marbles inside of this box.
And then I'm going
to hide either
your or Bunny's marbles
inside of this box.
Does that sound like fun?
And then we're going to
look for your marbles, OK?
If you find them, you
get another sticker.
All right, so I'm going
to put Bunny's right here,
and we're going to
do the hide game.
So first, I'm going to choose
either your marbles or Bunny's
marbles and put them in here.
I'm going to pour them in.
Look, somebody's
marbles are in here.
Now I'm going to do the
same thing with this box.
Either your marbles
or Bunny's marbles
are going to go in this box.
All right.
Are you ready to begin
shaking and listening?
So remember, over here,
there's either your marbles
or Bunny's marbles.
OK, let's listen.
[CLUNKING NOISES]
All right.
And over here, there's
either your marbles
or Bunny's marbles.
Let's listen.
[CLUNKING NOISES]
Cool.
Let's do it one more time.
[END PLAYBACK]
LAURA SCHULZ: We'll skip
the one more time, but--
oops.
Sorry.
You can at the
general principle.
The children are overwhelmingly
good at this kind of task,
it turns out, in
both of these cases
and in many, many other
iterations they went.
They're very confident
about which box
they should pick, which
means they're representing
to themselves something about
the ambiguity of the evidence,
and their own
ability to perceive
these kinds of distinctions.
So with Max, we've
been talking about this
as a kind of intuitive
psychophysics,
where they can represent
their own discrimination
threshold to make these
kinds of distinctions.
And they prefer
interventions that
generate distinctive
patterns of evidence
and maximize the possibility
of information gain.
Is that clear?
OK.
So there's a lot of
ways in which children
seem to be using intuitive
theories, some kind
of abstract, higher
order of knowledge,
to make inferences from data.
But information is also
costly to generate.
And the costs themselves
are informative.
So I'm going to talk a little
bit about that piece now.
It's costly both
for the learner,
who cannot learn everything.
And in a cultural context,
where you're not just
learning and
exploring on your own,
but you're actually getting
information from other people,
it's costly also for the
teacher or for the informant.
And these kinds
of costs, and how
we negotiate these
kinds of costs, I think,
are really fundamental
to a lot of hard problems
in communication and language.
Lots of the field of
pragmatics deals with problems
of underdetermination.
We say these sentences,
we understand each other.
We understand each other in all
kinds of ambiguous contexts.
We use a lot of social
cues and other information
to disambiguate.
But part of what we do
is, we make inferences
about how much this
person is going
to communicate in
this context, given
how much I need to understand.
And we use this to resolve
these kinds of ambiguities.
I'm going to give you a
few examples of that here.
Now, again, I'm going to
start with the study we
did a while ago then show you
a little bit more recent work.
I'm going to skip
over some of this just
to be able to cover
all of this and say,
Because there's a cost of
information for both teachers
and learners, it
predicts some trade-offs
in the kinds of inferences
you should make.
So for instance, if a
knowledgeable informant
shows you a toy and says, here,
this toy has a single function.
Then if you, the learner, think
that that teacher is trying
to generate a true sample
from the hypothesis
based on what actually
is going to get
the right idea to
your head, you should
assume that there is only
one function and not two,
or three, or four, or five.
Because if there were more, they
should have shown them to you,
right?
Because if they know
the true hypothesis,
and they could just
demonstrate that,
they can rule out
all of that for you.
But if you just stumble upon
a single function of a toy,
or a not knowledgeable teacher
generates it accidentally,
or if the teacher, as
Liz Spelke pointed out,
is interrupted in the middle
of that demonstration,
then you shouldn't assume that
that evidence is exhaustive.
It suspends that
inference, right?
Now, OK, well,
you showed me one,
but maybe there are
two, three, or four.
So it's only in
a condition where
I think you are a fully
informed, freely acting
teacher that I should assume,
well, look, if you are helpful,
knowledgeable teacher,
then the information
you give me should not only
be true of the hypothesis,
it should help me
distinguish that hypothesis
from available alternatives.
And what that means is,
there's a specific trade-off
between instruction
and exploration.
Because if I'm
instructed that there's
one function of the toy, I don't
need to explore any further.
But if I just happen to find
one function of the toy,
maybe I do.
So let me show you what
we did to test this.
We had a novel toy.
It actually had four interesting
properties, a squeaker,
a light, a mirror, and music.
And we demonstrated
a single function
of the toy, the squeaker,
in three conditions.
And we also had a baseline.
In the pedagogical condition,
we said, watch this,
I'm going to show you--
sorry, the alignment's off--
but watch this, I'm
going to show you my toy.
They pulled the toy and
then said, wow, see that.
OK, the accidental
condition was,
look at this neat
toy I found here,
accidentally pulled this tube
in the same way, wow see that.
The baseline was, just look
at this neat toy I have here,
with no demonstration.
And the interrupted
condition was identical
to the pedagogical condition,
except the teacher was
interrupted immediately
after pulling the tube,
and then she said,
wow, see that.
So is that clear?
I'm sorry for the
slide misalignment.
And the prediction is that
in the first condition,
children should constrain their
exploration relative to all
the other conditions.
So let me show you
what that looks like.
Or not.
Which is too bad, because this
is a really super cute slide.
But it's not going to work.
In this condition,
what we found was this.
We found a child in the
children's' museum with a toy
with all of these kind
of wow properties.
We say, wow, see this.
We show them the
property of the toy,
and the child spends 90 seconds
pulling only the squeaker.
He then says, I'm very
smart for a five-year-old.
And when she asks for all of
the other functions of the toy,
he doesn't know any of
the other functions,
because he hasn't explored.
And what we think is, he is
very smart for a five-year-old.
Because it's a completely
rational inference that,
if there were more
functions of the toy,
then they should have
been demonstrated.
And so what we find
overall is, in fact,
that children do fewer
actions, and they discover
fewer functions of this toy.
This isn't just true, it
turns out, we now know,
because we live in a
hyperpedagogical culture.
Because Laura Shneidman
and Amanda Woodward
just replicated this
study with Yucatec Mayan
toddlers and found the same
kind of effect, constraints
in the pedagogical
condition, even
though it's a
culture that's pretty
limited in their pedagogy.
So information is costly,
and pedagogical contexts
strengthen the inference that
the absence of evidence--
a teacher's failure to go on
and teach you more information--
is, in fact, evidence
of its absence.
Is that clear?
And this is a very
sensible inductive bias,
but it predicts that instruction
will, for better or worse,
constrain expression.
Because that's what
it's supposed to do.
It's supposed to constrain
the hypotheses you consider.
And indeed, it works quite well.
And that's good if you're
right about the world, right?
And it constrains it
to efficient learning.
But it's bad if you're
wrong about the world.
Because the unknown unknowns,
the things you don't know
are true that you
failed to teach,
are going to potentially
mislead a learner.
How much is enough information?
Well, there are
lots of good reasons
why teachers ought to provide
very limited information.
First of all, as I showed you
in the first set of studies,
evidence often supports
generalization.
Right?
One dog toy squeaks,
probably they all
squeak, barring how
generalizable that sample is.
So I don't need to show
you every single toy.
I don't need to
show a child, this
is a cup, and that's a
cup, and this a cup too,
and that's a cup,
and that's a cup.
Once the child has
a cup, I can assume
that that child herself
will be able to make
the rational generalization.
Or sometimes I know you're not
going to be able to make it,
but the additional information
is just too costly.
I'm working on teaching
you two plus two,
I'm not going to teach you
linear algebra right now.
It's a waste of our time.
So that's another
reason why you might
provide limited information.
So what are the contexts in
which omitting information is
a reasonable thing to do,
and when is it misleading?
When is this a real problem?
And the answer turns out to
be, if I'm the informant,
and I know I'm
providing information
that is going to lead you
to the wrong hypothesis,
then we consider that
a sin of omission.
Right?
If I'm omitting information,
and I'm not doing that,
then maybe that's not a problem.
So one of the questions
is, can children
distinguish these contexts?
Can they tell when the
teacher is providing
too little information, and it
is going to cost the learner
something in terms of what they
can gain, and when they're not.
So to test this--
this is again,
Hyowon Gweon's work--
we introduced a toy.
And it had one function,
this wind up mechanism.
And the kids got to
explore, and they found out
the toy did one thing.
In the other condition,
the toy looked the same.
But in fact, the toy
had lots of functions,
and the children knew that.
So the children always
knew the ground truth.
The toy either had
one function or four.
And then there was a
teacher who taught Elmo.
The teacher always
did the same thing.
taught just one function.
And the first question
was, the teacher's always
doing the same thing with
an identical looking toy.
Do the kids penalize
the teacher?
Do they think he's a
bad teacher if he only
teaches one function when
there are really four,
compared to when he teaches one
function and there's only one.
So the first thing we did was,
ask kids to rate that teacher.
And indeed, they think
that this teacher
is a terrible teacher when
there's four functions
and he only teaches one.
They think he's a good teacher
when he teaches one of one.
But the really interesting
question was, what would
the children do to
compensate if they
knew they had a bad teacher?
So we ran exactly
the same set up
where the teacher shows Elmo
the toy in the one function case
and the four function case.
And for reasons that
will become clear,
we also ran a control
condition where
there were four
active functions,
and the teacher taught all four.
In all cases, the
teacher then goes on
and runs that experiment
I just showed you.
The teacher shows
just the squeaker toy
here of this single function.
The question is, what
should the kids do?
So it's a complicated
set up, so I'll walk you
through it a little bit.
When you teach one
of one function,
you should infer the toy
probably does one thing,
it's a good teacher.
And so when they show
you one function of this,
you should constrain
your exploration,
say that was a
sensible inference.
When they teach one of
four, you should say,
that's a bad teacher.
The toy probably does
more than one thing,
the new toy probably does too.
I'm going to explore
more broadly.
But we don't know, in that
case, if they're doing it
because they just saw a
toy with one function,
and so they think this
toy has one function.
And they just saw a toy
with four functions,
so they think this toy
has four functions.
So we can disambiguate
those with this condition.
Now if they're just
generalizing from the toy,
this toy has four
functions, well,
then they should think this
toy has four functions.
But if they're generalizing
from the teacher,
this is a good teacher.
So when the teacher now
tells you about the new toy,
that it has one
function, the kids
should constrain
their exploration.
So does everyone understand
the logic of the design here?
And in fact, that's
exactly what we find.
The children compensated
with additional exploration
when they thought
the teacher had
provided insufficient
information to the learner.
Is that clear?
OK.
So information is costly
to teachers and learners.
If teachers minimize
their own costs
and provide too
little information,
children think
they're poor teachers.
They suspend the inference
that that information
is representative.
They compensate with
additional exploration.
I'm going to go ahead and
show you just a couple
more examples here.
There's too little information.
But because
information is costly,
you can also provide
too much information.
I might be doing that right now.
Too much information is costly.
It's taking a toll on the
learner to absorb all of that.
And you have to
know, well, are you
providing me too much
information, or just the right
amount?
And at the risk of falling
into this trap myself,
I am going to show you
quickly this study.
Because how much
information is too much
information depends on a
hard question which is,
how much do you already know?
Right?
You've all been here all summer.
You know a lot of things.
I'm not a very good
estimate of what you know
or how much this
information is going,
so it's a little
hard for me titrate
what's the right amount of
information to give you.
And the question
is, can children
take these kinds of
theory of mind problems
into account in order to
estimate what information they
should be getting?
To test this, we give
kids a 20-button toy.
If I push a single button and
it makes music, how many of you
think that all the other
buttons make music?
Because you can
generalize from data,
and that is a really good
inductive inference there.
They look the same, it's a toy.
One makes music,
they probably all do.
But suppose I go on
now to show you--
so that's your prior
expectation, they all work.
But that one doesn't work,
and that one doesn't work,
and that-- oh, that one works.
And that one doesn't work,
and that one doesn't work,
and that one doesn't work.
I'm doing this for a reason.
I know this is really boring.
It's partly to give you a
break, but it is also-- oh,
that one works.
OK, so now what you have
learned about this toy
is that actually, only
three of these buttons work.
And suppose I show you this
across a couple of toys.
You've just changed
your expectation.
Now if I show you
that one button works,
you don't think
all the rest work.
You think probably two
others work, right?
So if I bring out a brand new
toy, and I push this button,
you'll probably be
relieved if I just go ahead
and push these three, right?
And I don't go
around and show you
all of the inert
buttons on the toy.
Because information is costly.
You have to sit there through
all those demonstrations.
In this experiment, I'll
show you Gweon's work.
We gave kids a common
ground condition
where everybody shared prior
knowledge, this abstract theory
you can use to constrain your
interpretation of this data.
In this condition, there
were two toy makers,
who are the informants, and
there's two naive learners,
Ernie and Bert.
And in the common
ground condition,
Ernie, and Bert,
and the toy makers
are all there while the
child explores and finds out
that only three buttons
work on these toys.
OK.
And then one teacher
shows of a brand new toy
just like this every single
button, the inert ones
and the non-inert ones.
And the other teacher shows
just the three working buttons.
Right?
And then we say, hey,
kids, guess what?
We have a whole closet
full of more of those toys.
One of these teachers
can show them to you.
Which one do you want?
Which one do you want, OK?
The other condition is almost
the same, but guess what?
The child explores
on their own, right?
And so there's no common ground
about what these toys do.
And then the teachers
do the same thing.
One teacher shows
exhaustive information,
and the other teacher pushes
only the three working buttons.
So in this case, that efficient
information, that less costly
simple demonstration
could mislead the learners
about what the
true hypothesis is.
They have a prior that all
these buttons ought to work.
Which toy maker would
you rather learn
from depends on whether
the learners share
that prior background
information or not.
And that was true not only
when the children were
judging the informants, but when
they were teaching themselves.
So again, these are
four and five-year-olds.
The children had
a condition where
Elmo got to see that only three
buttons worked on the toy,
and the condition
where Elmo didn't
get to see how many of those
buttons worked on the toy.
And then the children got
to teach Elmo the toy.
And the children were much more
likely to press more buttons
and provide exhaustive evidence
in the no common ground
condition than the
common ground condition.
So children themselves
are adjusting
the cost of the
information they provide
based on their prior
expectation about what
they think the learner is
going to learn from the data.
What did we do is, lastly,
tell you a little bit about how
the costs of information
are informative
not just in figuring out
what data to learn from
and how you should
communicate information,
but in actually figuring
out what people are doing,
and actually grounding out
ordinary, everyday theory
of mind.
I'm going to start with an
example you're familiar with.
I know you've seen this before.
This is an experiment by Gergely
and Csibra, a rational action.
This little ball jumps over the
wall to get to the momma ball--
you've all seen this?
I think Josh was
presenting it maybe?
OK.
And when you took
the wall away, babies
expect that ball to
take an efficient route.
So we think that rational agents
should take the most efficient
route to the goal, they should
maximize their overall utility.
But there's a lot of reasons
why that ball might have jumped
over the wall, and they
all have to do with costs
of rewards of action.
One might be, it was really
hard to get over the wall,
but really rewarding to do so.
Another reason,
though, is that it
was really easy to get over
the wall, so she might as well,
but she didn't care that
much about the reward.
These could have the
same net utility,
but psychologically, you really
care about the difference.
If we're talking about
the internal structure
of an agent's
motivations, you want
to decompose this
simple argument
about rational,
goal-directed action
into what the particular
costs and rewards are.
So Julian Jara-Ettinger
in our lab
has developed this
account he calls
the naive utility calculus,
which is our way of reasoning
about other peoples' actions.
Which is, we assume other agents
are acting to maximize utility,
but we care about the
internal structure also.
There are agent invariant
rewards and costs.
Two cookies is always
more than one cookie.
Higher hills are always higher
than lower hills for all of us.
But some of us are more
motivated to get cookies
than others of
us, and some of us
find hills more costly
than others of us.
So in addition to
these agents invariant
aspects of costs
and rewards, there's
also these internal
subjective things that
are harder to judge, right?
How competent you are,
what your values are,
and your preferences.
And so understanding how
all of these worked together
lets you take a very,
very simple analysis
and make surprisingly
powerful inferences about what
other agents are doing.
I'm going to show
you a few examples
and actually connect
it back to how children
are scientists in this regard.
So here is an
example experiment.
Here is Grover, and there
is a cracker and a cookie
down on this low shelf.
And Grover goes ahead,
and he chooses the cookie.
And now there's a cracker
and a cookie and this shelf,
and Grover goes ahead
and chooses the cracker.
And the question is, what
does Grover like better?
Well, if your read
out of preferences,
it's your actions you take.
It's your goal-directed action.
You should be at chance--
you chose a cracker
once and a cookie once.
But if even young
children understand,
no, it's not that simple, right?
You're not just acting
to maximize reward,
you're acting to
maximize utility.
You have to take the
costs into account.
Then clearly his
preference is what
he chose when the costs
were matched, right?
Not when the costs
were mismatched.
And the children should
say, no, no, no, it's
what he chose on the low box.
Which treat does he like best?
Is that clear?
And indeed, that is
what children do.
You can also introduce
a couple of characters.
Cookie Monster, who has a
strong preference for cookies,
and Grover, who is indifferent,
who likes them both.
So for Cookie Monster, the
reward value of cookies
is much higher.
For Grover, they're equivalent.
And now you can
set up a situation
where there's crackers in a low
box and cookies at a high box.
And you say, guys, go on,
you can make a choice.
And Grover chooses
the cracker and Cookie
Monster chooses the cracker.
And you say to the kids,
which puppet can't climb?
Now, no puppet has climbed.
No puppet has failed to climb.
No puppet has even
thought about climbing.
But the kids can know
the answer, right?
Because if Cookie
Monster could climb,
and he had a high reward,
then who would do it.
So you don't really
know about Grover,
but you can make an inference
that the costs were not
equivalent.
And by the way, in case you're
worried that kids are just
saying, well,
Cookie Monster, I've
been listening to
Michelle Obama.
You know, obesity and
fitness-- cookies aren't good,
I can't climb.
We ran the same experiment
with Grover and clover,
and Grover really likes
clovers, and Cookie Monster
likes them both.
And you now flip the
inference around.
OK, so they can consider how
the costs affect the inferences
they make.
All right, so let's bring
this all back together.
I've thrown a lot
of information--
probably too much
information-- at you
about how kids can
reason from sparse data,
about how they use
their theories to make
these inferences, about how
they use this in teaching
and learning in social context.
But if kids are sensitive
to these utilities
and the trade-offs,
then the kinds of things
that I showed you them doing
with beads and with machines,
they should also be able
to do in social context.
We believe psychology to
be something of a science,
as well as all of
these other sciences,
and they should be
able to apply some
of the same principles--
holding some things constant,
manipulating others-- in
order to gain information.
So we basically ask that
question of the children here.
Can they distinguish agents'
different competencies
and rewards by manipulating
the contexts that they see
and gaining information?
So here, we don't know if
Cookie Monster can climb.
So let's put one
treat on each box.
Where should we put
the treats to find out
if Cookie Monster can climb?
Now, only one of these
interventions is informative.
If the cookie is
down low, and you
know Cookie Monster
prefers cookies,
then you're not going
to get any information.
But if the cookie
is up high, then you
are going to get
information, right?
And in fact, the kids are
overwhelmingly good at this.
In case you think, well,
treats should be put up high--
and this is also true,
by the way, for clovers,
but it's all right.
In case that you think they
just have a heuristic like,
oh, well, let's
put treats up high,
you can ask the question
a different way.
You can say, both of our
friends can climb the short box.
But only one of our friends
can climb the tall box,
and we don't know which one.
So let's put the cookie up
here and the cracker down here.
And if we want to figure
out which one of our friends
can climb, which friend
should we send in?
Well, Grover has no
particular incentive to climb.
He could just do the cracker.
But Cookie Monster, he
has an incentive to climb.
You should probably
send in Cookie Monster.
And again, these are
the kinds of inferences
that young children can make.
Is that clear?
All right.
So, end of a long winded talk.
I want to return it to this.
So I framed it in terms of
the way I've been increasingly
thinking, and the projects
that we're increasingly
moving towards,
which is thinking
not just about the pure pursuit
of knowledge and information,
but how do you pursue
information in a complex world
where it's not just your
own individual exploration.
You get it in a
social context, you
get in interaction with others.
The information is costly both
to deliver and to process.
But that, those costs
themselves, are information,
and you can use them to
make sense of the world.
And so I want to sort of bring
these together and come back
to a problem that I posed a
bit earlier, which is, I think,
I hope I've made the case
that what kids are doing
is not reasoning about
huge sets of data.
What kids are doing is, they're
taking some very abstract
structure knowledge and using
it to constrain their inferences
about tiny amounts of data.
Cookie Monster this, a
couple of trials of evidence.
And then they make
good inductive guesses,
which are sometimes
wrong, but they are good.
And I said, these
abstract representations,
not all of them
are innate, right?
You've seen beautiful
evidence of the many that are,
but a lot of them aren't.
A lot of them aren't.
A lot of the things that govern
your common sense knowledge
every day, how do you get those?
And how do you get those
from tiny amounts of data?
This is a problem that bugged
me deeply for a very long time,
and I think there's been a real
leap and a very exciting ascent
of how it is actually possible
to use tiny amounts of data
to make really rich
abstract inferences, which
then constrain
your interpretation
of subsequent data.
I think that is a really
important problem.
And with that, I'm
going to turn it over
to Josh and Tomer, who
maybe can tell you how
that is going to actually work.
So thanks to everyone
here at Woods Hole.